there's a negotiation going on with
nature that we need a lot more stem
knowledge to really carry through I
think but that negotiation is taking
longer than I expected and taking on
climate with a level of seriousness that
it needs to be addressed is taken much
longer than I expected
put in 68 he remember I was you know 29
year old no squat and one of the reasons
I did the Whole Earth Catalog is to
maybe the way you sort of did some of
these courses to learn about them was to
you know I was saying I'm gonna help the
people doing communes figure out how to
do all these basics they care about they
didn't know how refrigerators work they
thought you could grow a garden by just
sticking a stick in the ground and
throwing the seeds at it and got over
that and one season and then either gave
up or they actually learned how to do it
well I was one of those people who
wanted to learn all that stuff and so
the access to tools and skills was my
own desire to learn those things but you
know 29 year olds have a intense short
view of the world
and one of the great things about us
giving more older people around and you
will discover this as you get older is
your range of not only personal
experience expands but your sense of
participation and history expands
forward and back and more back the more
for it in a way and then you start to
get comfortable in the long story and
that's sort of what I impart these days
that make sense
you